- There's this
incredible axis point
of what you're great
at and what you love.
When you stumble into
being somebody like me,
you really win when what
you're naturally great at
is what you naturally
love the most, and away you go.
The amount of people
that I meet every day
that are great at something
but have no interest
in being a CFO.
They're insane with numbers
but they don't wanna do it.
They wanna sing. Right?
And so that's tough.
You see it in athletics.
People don't
understand athletes.
The amount of
athletes that just do it
because it was the
best way, in the same way
that somebody goes
and becomes an accountant,
and they don't love competition,
and they don't love the sport.
It's crazy when you look at them
'cause you're like,
you're one of the 15 best,
and they don't
love it which is why
they're not the
greatest athlete of all-time.
The greatest
athletes of all-time
are the ones who
love it and have it.
And so I think what you need
to do is taste everything.
It's kind of like food.
You don't know what
your favorite food is
if you only eat one food.
So I would take
advantage of your youth
and your flexibility at this age
and try to taste everything,
play with everything,
figure out what
you might be good at,
what you might like, and
then you make a decision.
(light music)